Dexter King describes what it was like
having dr. Martin Luther King jr. as a
father the void left by his father's
death and the murder of his grandmother
he also discusses the legacy of dr. King
and the inspiration he drew from his
mother Coretta Scott King this program
originally aired in 2003 it's just under
an hour
well first of all I want to say how
happy I am to be here in Pasadena and
Romans primarily because this is really
my inaugural book signing if you will so
hopefully you will feel as excited as I
feel about the first part of my book
tour also this is a very special time of
year as we began to reflect on my
father's birth his actual birthday being
January the 15th and of course
celebrating as a national holiday on the
20th next Monday so as we pause as the
nation pauses to reflect on his
teachings principles and life's work I
hope that we will all remember that the
message he left for us is really and
truly rooted within being our best
selves I always think of the fact that
people compared my father to so many
great icons but I would like to think of
him first and foremost as daddy to me he
was just simply someone I could seek
refuge in and I think that the book was
for me a great opportunity to get some
of these issues out on the table to look
back over the span of years and explore
the rich legacy that I'm very proud of
being a part of and the fact that he was
a very serious person in public the
public man that we all know but yet in
private he was very fun-loving very
playful in fact I saw him more as a
playmate than actually a father he
really enjoyed having fun and playing
with his his children we didn't get a
chance unfortunately to spend a lot of
time
to tea time but quality time we spent
was very memorable and enriching so I
talked about these many experiences that
I'll always cherish but I also deal with
the fact that at a very young age this
great tragedy that struck America that
struck all of us affected all of us in
some way left a very deep-seated feeling
of incompletion so the book in a real
sense helped me to bring this tragedy
full circle because my family really had
not dealt with my father's death in a in
a real substantial way in a real sense
we followed my mother's example of
strength and nurturing she was very
courageous and and stoic at the time of
my father's death so we we really didn't
get a chance to grieve if you will and
we moved on with our lives so as an
adult a young man I began to realize
that there was some issues that I had
not quite resolved that I had not fully
put in perspective so I needed a means
for addressing those feelings and
certainly having this opportunity to
write this book to to deal with the
memoir gave me a sense to of liberation
really for lack of a better word and
also being very cathartic and
therapeutic and all of those things that
helped us to really see our lives in an
objective sense so I also don't know
that many people are aware of the string
of tragedies that befell my my family
not just my father but my uncle my
father's brother who was like a
surrogate father after my father left us
and less than a year or I'm sorry sorry
a little bit after a year longer than a
year
just barely
a year after my father's death my uncle
passed away and then a few years after
that my grandmother and these were three
of really the closest people to me in my
growing up and the fact of the matter is
I was very confused with my
grandmother's death because she was
because of the way she was killed she
was killed in the church sanctuary by a
deranged gunman and at that age I was
old enough to really experience or
understand what death
in a very practical sense was all about
so it really had a major impact on me
this to the point where I questioned why
I asked God the questions of why did
this happen to such a wonderful person
and really the strength that I derived
from my grandfather and my other family
members was the thing that kept me going
the fact that I was with my grandfather
as my grandmother was being operated on
in the hospital in the emergency room
my grandfather my cousin and I walked
over to the prison ward of the hospital
because the the suspect had been
apprehended and also had sustained some
injuries and to witness my grandfather's
testimony to say to this deranged
individual that he actually would
forgive him for the heinous act that he
committed and as a 13 year old standing
there witnessing this helped to lay the
foundation for my sense of healing and
my sense of openness and my sense of
forgiveness I also was brought back or
rather it was brought back to mind that
in the late 50s my father
was actually autographing a book in
Harlem New York and a woman almost took
his life at that time a story that not
many people know about and he forgave
the woman that almost took his life from
a stabbing that occurred at a book
signing in New York and what it told me
growing up or what it taught me was that
you really do have to live your life in
such a way that you make the fullest of
your life because you really don't know
what tomorrow brings and it also teaches
me that it's important to make sure that
you have a strong spiritual grounding so
that you know within yourself that
you're being true to yourself into your
dreams so I am very proud to on one hand
have had such a rich legacy but also
having tragedy and trauma and hopefully
in the end can now say that I am
triumphant over tragedy so I don't see
myself as one who should be in any way
put on a pedestal that was the one thing
growing up that my father and and both
parents instilled in us that we were
normal ordinary people and I often tell
young people that my father did do
extraordinary things but he was an
ordinary man and he was a human being
who wanted like so many people to be a
part of society wanted believed in
community was a very compassionate
person a very warm person a very giving
person and I feel like all of those
values and all of those qualities were
instilled and all of my family members
so I I'm very proud as I said to have
that rich heritage and I would lastly
say that having this opportunity to be
in a real sense the first King sibling
if you will
King offspring
to have a book at this point to be
presented is a real honor and privilege
for me because it took a lot out of me
to be able to go inside and reach deep
down and tap into my innermost feelings
and my vulnerabilities and be true to my
own inner voice and this process really
has been liberating for me so I I thank
all of you for your interest in my story
and the fact that I will always continue
to uphold what I feel isn't a very
important legacy and the book also
touches on that fact that while I have
always had to balance this duality of
obligation inheritance with personal
ambition and desire and really in a true
sense they've become one because they
both represent me in a truly unified
sense so maintaining my identity as my
own self as my own man but yet being
very proud and very honored by my
father's legacy I think is something to
be very proud of I tell a story in the
book of how one of my bosses really gave
me a tough for lack of a better word
tough love tete-a-tete where he was
simply saying to me you know you can't
be down on your your luck so to speak
you can't feel pity for having lost your
father at such a young age and he went
on to tell me the fact that not only
should I be proud of having one great
parent or father but also a great mother
and having two examples two parents that
I can emulate and live up to so you know
having people like that in my life
influences who helped me to become the
man that I am today is something that I
have have to be proud of
so I feel like this process has taken me
to a point where I can now turn a new
leaf in a real sense and I can start to
focus on some of the things that Dexter
for Dexter and in a very healthy
self-interest way as my father used to
say in one of his sermons one of my
favorites are the three dimensions of a
complete life and he talked about the
importance of healthy self-interest as
opposed to selfishness and healthy
self-interest helps to enrich our
spirits so I am now at a place where I
feel I have put this very heavy burden
if you will in perspective and I can
truly I'll say that I am being true to
my calling into myself and I feel that
having this is so it's so unique it's
been such a unique experience for me to
have had this opportunity to really get
into the meat of who Who am I as a as a
human being Who am I outside of just the
son of Martin Luther King jr. and
Coretta Scott King but Dexter Scott King
in my own right so again I want to thank
each and every one of you for your
interest and remember as we embark upon
this great holiday that we think of it
in in the new definition of what my
father defined as greatness he defined
greatness through service to others the
greatest among you shall be your servant
so let us remember that really the King
holiday is not a day off but a day on
and a day that we should be giving back
to the community so at the King Center
we are urging everyone on that day to
really get involved in the community and
do for those who cannot do for
themselves and again I want to thank
each and every one of you and I guess at
this time I don't know we
going to open it up or four so I guess
at this time maybe we will take some
questions comments yes sir my mother is
very well she's busy as ever she travels
more than I do and I don't know how she
does that and we keep trying we're
trying to slow her down and I but at the
same time I feel like that's what keeps
her going and energizes her so as long
as she's happy I think that's the
important thing
thank you for asking I'm sorry do you
have any fear for your life any fear no
not in a real sense I try to live life
without looking over my shoulder so to
speak because that would be very
frustrating and you growing up I talk
about this in the book that we were
always under the threat of danger there
were I remember in school there were
kidnap threats levied on my family and
we had teachers going to school police
officers posing as teachers and and that
type of thing and I kind of joked about
the fact that my brother and I when he
got his license we were going driving
around somewhere as teenagers do and we
had this cop car fall this around it was
like cramping our style you know we
couldn't be kids so you know but that
was that was just kind of you know
danger was the constant companion but
you you don't at least we didn't live
our lives that way we were always
encouraged to just live a normal life
yes mom
deal with the weight of the legacy of
her husband I'm sorry how have I helped
her no have you I was observed her deal
with it well I think she's done very
well I mean and I expressed this in the
book how is saddened me or really
brought tears to my eyes to see that
when she and my father met and
subsequently got married they were in
New England or
Boston at the time and they had a lot of
privileges that they didn't have coming
back to the South since she was an
artist when she met my father she was in
the conservatory New England
Conservatory studying music concert
singer so they had to make a choice do
we go back to the south and give up some
of the privileges just simply going to
the Opera to ballet or any of the art
types events without having the
opportunity like in the South you knew
you would be sitting in the balcony or
you would have to enter from the rear
these sound like very small things
particularly to kids today who have no
real sense of of that era so it brought
tears to my eyes to for them both in
their early 20s I mean think of you know
what we were all doing at that point to
say no we have a contribution to make we
have to go back to our homeland in the
south to make it better for all people
so for me that inspired me to let me
know that she actually in many ways
inspired him and gave him a lot of the
impetus for instance she was a peace
activist at Antioch College long before
she met my father you know so the fact
of the matter is she had paid her dues
in many ways so when they met it was
almost as if you know it was a natural
partnership and she continued certainly
after his death by institutionalizing
and I feel in many ways popularizing
because in America we are very much into
symbols and a holiday is the time that
we can reflect and all of the work she
did to to raise the consciousness of his
work and his legacy I think is probably
the greatest tribute she could pay in a
lasting institutional sense yes sir
I would say probably about four years
yes yes I did
well I'm a very creative person I always
have been I have a love for music I have
a love for any type of creative outlet
that allows my voice to shine through I
think having grown up in a musical
family as I mentioned my mom and and
even my dad I feel like he was an artist
a musician if you will his voice his
oratory was very melodic and all of that
resonated in our home so for me I have
always tried to approach things in a in
a more creative sense for instance I'm
not a ordained minister and I did not
follow the tradition nor my brother in
terms of the traditional path that
people would expect for the son of
Martin Luther King jr. ironically my
sister was the woman and you know I
always say God works in mysterious ways
because that was I think for her her
spiritual grounding she was only five
years old and did not know my father
never really got a chance to know him
she only knew him through photographs
and other memories so she needed that
outlet for her I think to bring her
closer to that to his spirit for me it's
it's really about the creative outlet
yes why don't you go first in new second
thank you doctor you mentioned that sort
of in passing that to a lot of younger
people having to enter a theatre through
the back door or having to sit up in the
balcony might seem rather trivial I grew
up in New Orleans and I was actually 11
years old when the Civil Rights Act of
1964 was passed and I remember very well
as a as a dear high school student not
being able to go into certain movie
theaters and having a drink from
different water fountains than white
Americans and and and having not being
able to sit down at Lund
and eat a hamburger for lunch I remember
all of that stuff and very very well
however when I try to have discussions
too as just a simple history lesson to
young people these days both white and
black and other so often met with a
response that I'm wallowing on it it's
in the past get over it it was a long
time ago why do we have to keep
revisiting this that's the trouble with
America the trouble of America is that
we can't let it go I was wondering if
you might share your thoughts with us on
those sentiments that in my experience
not all certainly but but many young
people seem to have and that reaction
that many young people seem to have -
just learning the history sure well
first I think we have to do it again in
a creative way the traditional way
sometimes can be somewhat intimidating
and to some kids condescending so I
think we do have to be careful not to
seem as if we're force feeding this
important message and secondly the the
sad fact of it is that we should not
have to quote dwell or harp on it the
reason I believe we still are doing that
is because we really have not dealt with
it at the core root level so we're
dealing with it superficially or
ceremonially and not sacramentally until
we start to deal with it at the heart
and spirit level then we will begin to
understand because the first argument is
made well I didn't do it or and it's and
the thing about spirit is that it passes
on generationally so until we deal with
it at that level it's not about words
it's really about what's in your heart
so I think that's the way we have to
approach and make sure we're doing it
with love in our hearts and not again
trying to to beat someone over the head
with a stick of self-righteousness
because no one can hear a message
packaged or presented in that fashion
thank you what it's going to ask about
the book itself again you talked about
going deep with them to write the story
and being that you had to grow up very
much in the public eye and your whole
family I'm wondering what kind of either
collaboration or response your family
has toward the things you've written
about obviously I haven't read it yet
but I can imagine if you really gone
that deep you've probably written some
stories and I don't know if he took them
from a point of being very loyal to the
family and the memory or just being
really honest with how Dexter felt about
the things and just pretty much how they
feel about the stories and the books and
things you've done there I wrote from a
vantage point of honesty my editor first
thing he said to me and my collaborator
was you know you really have to put
everything out on the table and then
it's up to us the editors to figure out
you know because you can't put
everything it hopefully ties together in
a narrative sense and hopefully it flows
in a way that everybody can can follow I
do believe the first half of the book
was most emotional for me and I think it
comes through that way because that was
the part dealing with the tragedies but
the stories for instance I tell a story
about the only time I really saw my dad
get upset was the time that my sisters
and brother or really my sister and
brother hidden his cigarettes and people
are like well I didn't know your dad got
upset I didn't know your dad smoked
shame on him and you know the fact of
the matter is I remember as a youngster
or a younger man someone swearing me
down in public your dad did not smoke
and I'm holding a picture of him holding
a cigarette you know and it's like he
was a human being now granted he did not
smoke until the latter part of his life
when the movement became so stressful
and that was an outlet and sure we don't
like to think about anyone that we put
on a pedestal having flaws but he was a
human being so that the reality is I was
very honest first because I was told
that that is the only way you're going
to get through this process and it's the
only way that
people will understand the story if they
can identify with it if you if you write
from a again a superficial vantage point
people see right through that so I for
many reasons needed to put it out there
but I don't think there's anything in
the book that's so alarming that people
say gosh I I'm appalled by that but then
you never know people have different
opinions and that's their prerogative
yes still alive today do you have any
thoughts on what he would feel about
race relations in America today
gosh that's that's the hard way I think
in many respects he would be very
alarmed and disturbed but I think he
would also acknowledge that we've come a
long way the fact of the matter is his
work was not complete and his life was
cut short so the the continuum or the
full circle part of reconciliation did
not occur and if you really understand
his philosophy it really was rooted in
the love ethic and he talked about the
importance he often talked about I was
inspired by Christ and I got my
technique from Gandhi so when you look
at the way the civil rights movement
happened there was a methodology it
wasn't just ministers feeling the spirit
and saying oh we're gonna March today
you know that was part of it but they
thought about very methodically and
strategically where do we get the most
mileage whether we do a sit-in today or
a boycott and they really thought about
also how do we do this in a way that we
allow our opponent to save face so that
after all of the tension clears up we
can come back together and join hands so
that's the the problem today as I see it
is many activists not all but many of
them who don't really study my father's
teachings go straight to direct action
which is to confront rather than doing
information gathering which is the first
step of non-violent reconciliation and
that's what we have to we really just
have to look read his teachings and go
back
the basics and it's all there so a lot
of our problems could probably be solved
if we sought to find more of our things
we have in common rather than the
differences yes sir many social and
political careers in America have risen
to prominence on the coattails of your
father's legacy and some of the
association's that they have proclaimed
to have with your father some are very
well based and they're very just the
file but there have been some that are
very loose and they've kind of taken
that to promote their own career and my
question is at times is this really how
has your family felt about this and how
have you felt about it well you know
certainly it's disheartening at times
because you you really don't want people
who are not familiar with his message to
book to get the impression that this is
the way this is you know a lot of people
I say will will carry my father's name
around on a banner and that's that's
their calling card so to speak but they
may talk the talk but not necessarily
walk his talk and we have to help
everyone to understand go to the source
I often hear people they come run up to
me in the airport or wherever oh I read
this great book about your dad and I
always say that's wonderful but have you
read his writings have you read my read
my dad's writings the amazing thing
about him is that we don't have to guess
he actually was so I don't know how I
did it amazing in the sense that he
chronicled his work as it was happening
so sure it may take time to piece it all
together but it is there so my point is
is we don't have to allow an
interpretation let's read what he talked
about let's read about Selma let's read
about Montgomery let's read about
Birmingham there's so many stories
they're the stories within stories that
can give you insight into how all of
this came about as a human being what he
was feeling what the people around him
were feeling so I say let's let's not
allow anybody no matter who it is to
tell us how we should do what we know is
right and it's really self empowerment
yes sir probably don't remember me this
is not even a question I met you are
back in 1987 in New Jersey Atlantic City
New Jersey and a good book that would be
would be the testament of hope the
essential writings of dr. King and in
there I think is one of the greatest
species your father ever gave and I told
you that in Atlantic City it was a drum
major instinct and there's so many
parallels the way life is today but at
that time I told you that since I was
able to purchase the tape in anything
after your father went with good lord I
would put myself to sleep listening to
your father's speeches on tape and that
shaped a lot of my life I told you and
it's some day that when I would have
children that I would teach my children
your fathers are what your father had
reached and lived and next to my Bible
is that book and I read even last night
the drill major inside mr. I already
know it by heart
but I just want that you know that on I
kept that promise to you and I I've been
stole those things of your father of my
children
yes sir Jackson compliment dear dad
asset to his life or liability
I think remand Jackson in many ways has
made a lot of contributions to the
efforts of social change and civil
rights certainly without his voice in
the community a lot of issues would go
unnoticed and that's not to say in any
way that Reverend Jackson is is perfect
certainly we know that he has had some
personal challenges in more recent times
I think you have to judge a person the
good with the bad and you have to look
at it in totality certainly there's a
lot that can be done that maybe he's not
addressing but again I think that goes
back to the point I made just a minute
ago that I don't think it's fair to
place the burden on any one person
because I find myself in that position
where people come up to me and when I'm
doing interviews a lot well what do you
think the problem how should black
people deal with this or that or race
and I'm saying well it's not just a
black issue you know it's a human issue
and until we elevate it to the level of
people of goodwill versus people of
ill-will doesn't matter what color your
skin is because the issues are the same
that affect us all and that to me is the
spiritual part that we have not evolved
to that my father I feel was trying to
take us to he kept saying don't focus on
me the man focus on the message he said
I won't be here I won't get to the
promised land with you but we as a
people will because he understood if you
focused on him once he was gone
everybody would be down and oh where do
we go now and lost nice no go within
within yourself and that's what I
challenge everyone to do to not place
anyone on a pedestal you know in terms
of a mortal being because we are all
fallible and we we are prone to make
so no one's perfect and no one has all
the answers it's the collective of all
of us working you know in collective
consciousness that makes a difference
says something he's under attack and so
I kind of I kind of wonder how would if
your dad was living I always think about
that if he was living how would he be
received today I always think about that
I think that's interesting because near
the end of his life it was probably the
most depressing part of his life of his
journey it's very interesting that when
my father gave the I have a dream speech
he was very much uplifted and applauded
when he won the Nobel Peace Prize when
he was time man of the year he was very
much applauded in fact he was a media
darling but the minute he took a stand
against the establishment the war in
Vietnam poverty issue when he wanted to
organize the quote original rainbow
coalition of poor Appalachian whites
Native Americans Mexican Chicano Mexican
Americans rather and African Americans
to come to Washington to deal with
poverty this time not jobs peace and
freedom like in 63 but to deal with the
real issue of poverty that at that time
the Johnson administration had this
quote war on poverty and and Congress
had allocated funds to deal with this
issue but yet we know that funds went to
the Vietnam War well the fact of the
matter is I don't know how he would have
been received after his death or today
because he was under so much pressure
character assassination all kinds of
attacks
spiritually even people within his ranks
with you know his colleagues because he
took a stand and there were those who
said other civil rights leaders who said
you know can't attack the war and he
said you know I if I'm the last
person to take a stand I will do that
because it's right to take a stand but
he could not be bought you know some of
them had to take the position they took
and he told him he said look I don't
blame you I understand you but maybe you
received a grant from the Johnson
administration or maybe your
organization can't be proactive you know
maybe you have to be more politically
correct
he understood those realities but he
said I cannot he he could not allow his
conscience to be governed by that so who
knows maybe death for him was really the
ultimate statement and martyrdom in
terms of his message getting out there
because the truth is people may not have
listened if he had lived so I don't know
it's a strange duality and I don't know
if any of us are prepared to answer that
question sure his speech at that I have
a dream speech he mentioned but I will
wish my children would not be judged by
the content the character and the part I
dislike very much was when the fight
against affirmative action they used
that took it out of constant use that
mind of the king and a lot of people
voted against for affirmative action
because they used that statement but
they don't know that dr. King said in
another book I think it was in the book
nice try struck freedom huh where to go
from here
he said the Negro is behind 200 yards
behind said he's 200 years behind he
said take for example a baseball Paris
run is behind
200 yards years how can they catch up
without you given the Negro something
extra give him a little leeway give him
a little head start so that's where I
took my friend for action for Forex I
took my source from there I'm a writer
so I wrote about dr. King and that
respect for kids and every year we have
a month the King Program in the Civic
Center and West Covina and each year I
put out something for the youth to know
cos the youth don't know that much about
King
so Wednesday I'm giving a symposium
about what did dr. King do and anyone
who wants to come Canada by block Lucas
library at 3:30 but we're talking about
what I have not learned what didn't dr.
King will he do and I had eight things
he did one was the letter from
Birmingham jail which I believe was but
it really it was his most published work
letter from Birmingham jail and that was
the best speech I like led to the clergy
and he just told him off you know in a
way I don't believe in America that the
people behind the stained-glass windows
are the very ones on this earth
promoting evil another one was when he
was stoned in Chicago like people know
he was stolen when you finally went to
live in Chicago in the slums and the
gate the gauge district section of
Chicago gage Park what it was and they
stone him because she won't have to
speak against March and against
slumlords I think that's the first time
I heard of slum Lords when he coined he
made of corn that played landlord slum
Lords anyway he was stoned almost not to
death but just stone and he did so many
things he was asked to go to sometimes
he was asked to go to other people's
marches that wasn't his cause like the
sit-ins that wasn't his cause and greens
broccoli that wasn't his cart but they
called him and said doctor you gotta
come he didn't want to go to Memphis but
he came because of those two men sitting
in the garbage truck at a sanitation
truck
someone could 11 crushed him then he
came back he'd been there before but
there was a riot broke out so he went
home and Mark at March 28th is anyone
came back and everybody made him come
back that became an agent we need you so
that's where he met his death when he
went back there gave that speech on
mountaintop speech April 3rd in the
Bishop Charles Mason
auditorium there in Memphis the site of
the Pentecostal church movement so I'm a
doctor Michael King stops me
well I I think the the most and thank
you for for that display of great
historical fact the on a serious point
though the the fact of the matter is my
father in so many ways his message and
legacy has been defined by the media and
I don't say that in a pejorative sense
I'm simply saying that the visual media
is limited in terms of what it can
exploit by way of sound bytes and
frankly that I have a dream speech I
always refer to it as the top 40 of my
father's repertoire it was the hit song
if you will but there was many there
there many many more speeches sermons in
his repertoire which warner books has
done a great job at compiling many of
those and a lot of people don't realize
that they they have not heard at all
that's the other sad part of it is that
because of his greatness in such a short
period of time the great level of
greatness he achieved people feel like
oh I already heard that I already know
the story so they overlooked it but the
truth is we've published and unpublished
never-before-heard speeches and sermons
in recent times that really may not have
received the commercial success because
people don't know as I said and the last
thing is you know that I have a dream
soundbite and the very eloquent point
you made about causes using the content
of your character for maybe their cause
I'm not saying that it's disingenuous
because they may very well believe that
but I think what I always try to remind
them is that my father spoke a lot of
times in in metaphor and he the
beginning part of the speech which most
people never heard or read or and you
know he talks about that as you know
that the problem the bad check that
America wrote to them it's Negro
citizens and basically we are coming
back to the bank of Justice because we
know it's not bankrupt to ask for our
rights
so really the beginning part of the
speech talked
about the condition the last part of
speech talked about the ideal where we
should be working towards and you have
those who believe we're already there
and want to fast forward if you will to
the ideal and not deal with reality of
where we are so we have to do both and
it really is about balance how did those
things affect you in terms of your
spirituality and sure well I I did have
questions as a thirteen-year-old as I
said watching my grandmother be gunned
down in a church you know that's very
traumatic and I think it was my
grandfather who told us and I talked
about this in the book how he called us
all together and said you know I have to
stay around because at first he was
talking crazy saying you know maybe I
need to go on home and meet my maker and
then he said you know because he lost
the closest thing to and his bunch as he
called her for a bunch of goodness short
for a bunch of goodness and my
grandmother Big Momma is we refer to her
was such a sweet woman I mean didn't
harm anyone so it was just so it just
seems so out of place if it had happened
to him and actually the gunman was
coming to get him but it just so
happened he was not in the pulpit that
Sunday but you know not that we would
have accepted it but you know we knew he
was more visible than that kind of thing
but you know again my grandfather helped
us to understand through his strong
spiritual foundation that it was not for
us to question this that this was God's
will and that he had something better in
store for her but what made it work for
me was for him to say he had
grandchildren left he said you have to
be thankful for what you have left
and before he was thinking maybe he
would gone home but now he realized he
had to be here for us so he stayed
around another 10 years and he said you
know I'm thankful that I have my
grandchildren left so be thanked his
message was be thankful for what you
have left yes I've had people that you
wouldn't know not famous people but
people in my life along the way who have
given me lessons kernels of inspiration
I tend to value not so much what a
person says but what they do you know
people many people can talk the talk the
very few people walk the talk and what
inspires me is when I see want someone
who lives their life by example not
saying that any of us are perfect or in
no way am I saying that in a
hypocritical sense because we all you
know falls short but I'm saying that in
terms of for me my dad was such a great
examples that stepping outside of being
his son just the fact that he practiced
what he preached and and that is what
separated him I believe you know from so
many others who you know had the great
oratory of the gift that you know
Baptist preachers that that was never a
shortage of people who could say those
very you know powerful words but to
apply it in a sense I mean I know
growing up us living in Vine City and a
lower-income neighborhood growing up
when my grandfather wanted us to live in
a middle-class neighborhood and he said
no because people living standing on a
mountain if you're standing on the
mountain shouting and they're in the
valley they can't hear you
so he made sure that we grew up in
environments as you mentioned when we
lived in Chicago he took us to live in
the slums I remember living in a riot
torn community watching the the rioting
and everything all of that shaped me
growing up in terms of my care
so for me if it's not just talking the
talk it really is setting living your
life by example that it inspires me well
I can only tell you what came out during
a trial in December of 99 there was a
wrongful death trial filed in Memphis by
my family against the gentleman by the
name of Loyd Jowers and it's very
detailed so I won't go into all of it
now because it's very I think well
chronicled in the book but the end
result of that trial was that over a
period of about a month 70 witnesses
testified that do have in my opinion
credible evidence that it was entered
into the public record and at the end of
that trial a jury of 12 men and women
which I consider to be very independent
half black half white young old male
female they're very equally mixed down
the middle came back in less than two
hours with a verdict that there indeed
was a government conspiracy to kill my
father
and this gentleman Loyd Jowers was
considered to be a cog a small cog in a
big machine but if you ever you know
take the time to do the research the
trial transcripts are available on the
King Center's website at the King Center
org and the book also talks about it
touches on it thank you coming from a
creative family what are your hobbies or
interests in the arts can you tell us
that well unfortunately I don't get as
much time as I would like to so I'm now
starting to get back into it one of the
ways that I accessed my creative outlet
was to pay tribute first and foremost to
my dad's holiday the first national
holiday by doing a record producing a
record it was like a wheel the world
type compilation with many young artists
and it featured everyone from Whitney
Houston to Run DMC and it was actually a
mixed rap and song singing and rap
combined and it was a way of educating
young people about my dad's message in a
way that was not so preachy but yet fun
and creative so that that was one of the
things I was really proud of because it
accomplished a lot of things when I see
a lot of the artists today and in fact
part of that record was recorded right
here in Pasadena I recorded a new
edition at that time the group new
edition right here you know in Pasadena
and the studio owners were very generous
enough to donate the studio time in fact
the entire project was a labor of love
so I'm looking to express and get back
into it I'm not also producing some film
and television projects as well so I'm
really using my voice in in many
different ways actually thank you
the King Center is the official living
memorial to my father an institutional
Guardian but primarily what it does is
educate the public about his legacy and
work and we do that through many
programs most visible time of the year
is during the national king holiday and
I talked about the fact that service is
a big part of what we promote we also
have a strong internet presence where we
are developing teaching modules for kids
to learn more about how to resolve
conflicts with violence without violence
non-violently and
many other programs that you can learn
about going to the King center.org
one more
uplifting and also a couple days ago I
heard the Vietnam speech and it seemed
that it was truly his spirit with these
people who are demonstrating peacefully
right against a wall and the speech yeah
it's hard for me too yeah you said you
wanted to know more about my brother you
said oh okay recently was that okay well
he is my brother of course is the
namesake so he has such an awesome
burden as Martin Luther King the third
and yet I think he wears it well because
his personality I think is more geared
towards that whereas I'm probably more
of a behind-the-scenes person but he
heads the organization that my father
founded the Southern Christian
Leadership Conference SCLC which is
really more of a direct action activist
organization it's really the for lack of
a better word the frontline organization
with the King legacy so you will see him
and hear him from time to time speaking
out on very topical issues of the day
and I will certainly pass on to him that
you are inspired by his is you know
speeches and the spirit I I think he he
really he has a big heart and he really
cares about people sometimes too to his
detriment and I always say the key to
any public life if you're living giving
your life to public service you also
have to balance it because you you want
to be around so that you can continue to
give back you know receive and to give
well this has been wonderful and I wish
I could do this all evening and
unfortunately they're saying we have to
cut it short but again thank you for
your interest your the the I can feel
the energy and fill your spirits and the
the real sincere and genuine questions
you've posed and comments you've made
please continue to to keep my father's
dream alive and may God continue to
bless each and every one of you